it has been a really special week so it
was Wednesday he flew into Dublin and
then Thursday he went to see the Irish
president and he did a walkabout he
planted a tree and he also rang a bell
and then he stopped to you know
basically gesture with the American
Media who were asking him about leaks
and Northern Irish journalists were
asking him about the Good Friday
agreement and I just couldn't help
myself I had to get a question in and I
I did start the questions actually I
started the questions and I just came
out with it and said Mr President Mr
President and I have a selfie and then
he walked he just started walking away
but then he came back he came back and
he said um yeah no problem and then my
phone was actually broken so I borrowed
a phone from Amanda from A lady called
Amanda Ferguson and then he took the
actual selfie he took the selfie
um himself so I'm glad he did Henry
because my hand would have been
absolutely shaking so here he is he's
coming back over to you and whose phone
was it then so it was a lady from the
Washington Post the lady that asked the
northern Irish peace processor question
and I said can we have a phone up here
can we have a phone and we've got the
phone and I actually whispered in his
ear and I said to him in his ear I
actually said um Mr President I'm sorry
I'm looking so scruffy I'm this hard
he's 19 years old and this hat is
actually from Greece and he said well
you know it's going to ruin your
reputation and he smiled he shook my
hand and he walked off and I was just
dumbfounded and I know I broke protocol
I know I perhaps shouldn't have done it
and a few people have said journalists
shouldn't be asking um you know
politicians for selfies but in the
spirit of it in the spirits of the
celebration his Irish Roots he did the
serious stop up in Northern Ireland when
he came down to the Republic he was
doing the fun stuff uh visiting Ballina
and it was a celebration and I've got
the sale healthy and I'm just so proud
of it I'm so proud to meet him the guy
I'm going to say something a little bit
controversial I think he's more
charismatic than Bill Clinton or even
Barack Obama I mean wow I know and and
the energy for an 80 year old man that
he brought to Ireland uh Chris crossing
the country was just something else and
and I I suppose I'll remember it forever
and I know perhaps I should have been
asking more serious questions but it's
not every day you get a selfie with the
president absolutely and they I have no
regrets I have no regrets whatsoever I'm
actually celebrating here
look Henry tell me have you posted it up
on social media then yeah it's up on my
Twitter feeds it's up on at Henry McKeen
and um you know right across the world
you guys televise that live yourself it
was old-fashioned viral as and it was
globally being broadcast Across America
and the world and you viral as well and
people have been ringing me well wishes
so many people have said well done
people have come out of the woodwork
even up here in Donegal in the downings
in the harbor Park people are coming up
people are actually wanting to get a
selfie with me oh wow so you're the
celebrity now Henry well no no I mean
you're showing pictures there of Ballina
and falina was just so brilliant I mean
what what a rock concert the Coronas The
Chieftains and the president of the
United States going back to his home it
was a homecoming I mean it was just it
was it was something else and I know
he's the leader of the Free World Henry
um Legend